"City of London" has a unique location, it is a city within a city in a state within a state
By holding the most complex elections to elect a government, which includes
Medieval guilds, modern companies, luxury titles and hats. All are related
Some are in a very complex sketch, but why this complexity?
Although modern skyscrapers may make you think the city is relatively modern,
But it is the oldest government on the island of Great Britain and continues.
The "City of London" preceded the empire ruled by Victoria and the kingdoms that Anne united
And the Magna Carta document signed by John.
London, which surrounds the city, elected its first mayor in 2000
The list of mayors who managed the city of London is about 700 people
More than a thousand years ago.
The Government of "City of London" is so old that there are no documents to indicate
Found, there are documents such as the Magna Carta that I mentioned earlier, which remember the powers
"City of London" existed by then.
While a government such as the United States Government derives its power from the people,
The parliament derives its power from the royal crown, (which derives its power from the Lord)
"The city of London: derives its strength from its" long life "in the sense that the city is very old.
This age brings strange and unconventional habits, most notably these habits,
That in the "City of London" elections, companies can vote.
Really a lot! About 3/4 votes are cast by companies
While the remaining quarter of the population. The way this election works is that all that the company has grown up
All that came to the voices of more than the "City of London." Then the companies give their votes
For a selection of staff who work but do not live in the city
These officers are already voting on the date of the election.
The result is that the elected council, with its bureaucracy beating the heart
"City of London", containing approximately 20 members elected by the population for 80 members
Elected by city companies.
The reason behind this unconventional tradition is that it is for everyone living in
"City of London," 43 people arrive daily. With a total of 300,000 expatriates using
City services and their employment depend on the fact that "City of London" has a business environment.
The man who heads the elected council and is at the head of the city government is
"Lord the Honorable Mayor of London".
Now, suppose you "you" want to be Lord Mayor
Sure as in other London all you need is
(A) be a British national, a Commonwealth or a European citizen;
B) lived in the city for a year, which is who
C) won the elections
Right? Certainly not, in the City of London this is not enough at all. Is ready
For a list of requirements?
Before entering the race for the post of Lord Mayor must be sheriff "City of London" "Chief of Police".
But before you are sheriff of the city, you need to be a member of the local council.
What is a member of the local council? Well, "City of London" is segmented into 25 parts, and each part is elected
One member of the local council to represent them in the local council, which is part of
Popular Council.
Before you can compete for local council membership you need to get the title of Freedom City. It is able to give you,
Freedom City title? Not a member of the local council you are trying to enter
mechanism.
Which may be seen as a conflict of interest. Fortunately there is another way to get the title of Freedom City
He joined a union, unfortunately not called unions, but called them
Cooperative companies (the name is boring and less descriptive), but it remains
Unions of the Middle Ages, many of which are still within the city, there are about 108 of them to choose
Examples include:
Pharmacists
Fish vendors
Freemasons
Textile suppliers
Scientific Equipment Manufacturers
The bankers
Carpenters
Tire makers
The butchers
Bakers
Two different groups of candlestick makers
And most exciting: legal accountants!
Many of these unions, such as darts, have become charitable unions, but some are still
Effective, such as gold workers who inspect the British currency and the Vauxhall vehicles
The horses who licensed as taxi drivers.
To join one of these unions you will need either to meet the professional requirements,
Or charity such as clothing vendors will need the approval of two current members,
Others will not tell you how to get membership.
If you do not have any membership requirements, you think you are
You may come and start your "special" union to guarantee yourself the title of freedom of the city,
Will face a great deal of success because the new unions need to agree, as I expected,
Local Council.
But suppose you've guaranteed the title of Freedom City one way or another, now
You can enter the race on the membership seat for one penalty - after the approval of an adviser
Advisory Committee.
But, that's a simple hindrance. You can win a seat in the local council in one
4 parts in which the population lives or in one of 21 parts where the headquarters of the companies.
When you become a member of the local council you can now complete your way to become mayor in the municipal building,
You must now elect a city sheriff, but now members of cooperative companies
Who chooses Sharif.
So "if" you choose the members of the cooperative companies as honorable, after successfully completing your legal period
"Now" can enter the race on the mayor's platform.
But, to the surprise, the people of "City of London" do not vote for the mayor,
It is our old friends in the local council who do it.
In short, when you get the title of freedom of the city either from the local council
Or cooperative companies and after you are elected as a member of one of the parts of the city in the local council and promised to choose cooperative companies
For the post of sheriff and after you complete the legal period and at the same time I am still a member of
Local Council You can compete for the post of mayor.
Assuming that other members of the local council are senior in your choice, you can finally become
"Lord the Honorable Mayor of London", for one year only, and without salary. As you should
Cover your expenses yourself, which will be huge because your new business includes
You have delivered hundreds of speeches throughout the year and marketed the city around the world.
But you will be able to get that luxury hat, which makes it worth the suffering.